Magic City is a strip club when you walk
in you throw money and girls get but
complete naked like they take their
bottoms off and they take the top and
they shake the ass wait
Bert this vid con man sippin on perfect
in the other table man my man finally we
made that sort of leaving from magic and
then I made it like it I made this song
at 11 o'clock in the morning live a you
gorgeous strippers money everywhere hot
wings it's not a strip club if you don't
have money on the floor with hot wings
in it you got to have like an eating
bone of a hot wing on top of the money
we're like a stripper Hill that's off
this right there and bottles plenty of
bottles and empty cups that's the
American dream I felt like I made it
money
loud music the stars the beautiful women
you know the whole culture it was like
you were in the middle of a music video
Tupac been in there biggie
all the great celebrities hey you got
the hottest DJ a DJ ESCO who breaks a
lot of artists everybody comes in there
they want to shake his hand be a part of
the movement it's the hottest city in
the country in music it's like Motown
was in the 70s with groups on every
corner sing and trying to get to do it's
the same thing in Atlantis rap I love
you
yes because he has gonna be the most
important night magic City Monday
everyone is my friend on Monday in
Atlanta it's like the black cheers you
know everybody knows your name
maybe one day your talent can bring you
uh the treasure you know if you follow
your dreams another day cause I dumped
futures car a couple of times I've done
Rico waves car to Chinese car one day I
was watching
ESCO car and made him set in the car and
we he played some beats on me and I
wrapped over me having kind of have a
good relationship you know far as me
just washing his car and he comes up
there by about some time anything that's
coming out at Lana right now if the DJ's
play your music then it's gonna spread
worldwide voila
CD darlin sound like someone who watched
my career
I was broke like I grew up like broke
the 295 just wasn't cutting it so cliche
um I was in college and I couldn't pay
for my classes I made roughly anywhere
between fifteen to twenty thousand my
first weekend I was shocked I'm like
this is this is it like I'm gonna be
doing this one minute but stigma it's
kind of coming off of the names stripper
we don't have movie star than Alana so
the strippers on the movie stars like
they're high class socially in Atlanta
and so that's why the strip club is a
dream you make money for free just by
dancing who doesn't want to dance and
make money for free I'm isolating the
muscles in my butt and swinging my hair
to make it look sexy
[Music]
your track how you get your money and so
the trap is everybody runs their setup
differently you know what I'm saying
it's like a corporation so some people
hold on day money some people spending
everybody got different amounts coming
in and it's like a trap like if your
trap boom in your trap Bowman some
people strap ain't always booming you
know what I'm saying so that's how it is
that's how it goes this is my money make
your move everywhere I go it's my booty
I stopped traffic I call it car
accidents I get me in trouble with it
wives I don't mean to do it on purpose
but it happens all the dances are about
too much ass even though there's no
studies to show that the fatter they ask
the more money the guy has nonetheless
it doesn't stop them from trying I've
seen girls with perfect bodies in my
opinion they were like no no no no I
need to get more ass I need to pump it
up and I'd be like oh my god then you
see them like a couple of days later any
light
she did it if somebody spent a 10,000
and you just the money just going in the
air it just makes you be you wonder you
turn it up you're just going stuff now
this time I got like maybe two three
hundred dollars you just you simple you
you know you turn you to step it's a
twenty dollar there
[Laughter]
it didn't when you know you say thank
you so much yeah and did you just okay
your $20 dances over guys they just they
just want me to bust it open we say
busted over that means like just bend
over and just spread everything and I'm
not doing that for $10 I might do it for
10,000 I'm not going if it's not the
craziest thing for me that I've been
asked to do was go home with you I am
NOT going home to choose we do not go
home with Charlie we work at Magic City
we are not Martians walking down the
street trying to sell somebody day like
a 10,000 dollar spender and he executed
I'm going to say everything in the world
to him to make him believe I am coming
home with him and then I will hop out
that back door and get in my car and go
home listen it's hard people think it's
easy it's not using me to do they're not
just naked Fairlake there thank you
that's a that's a cool word we use
around here it's called go naked because
naked is one thing you know a lot of
people can get paid just to stand still
naked you know what I'm saying you could
probably pay me a little bit of mine I
was standing here naked you know you
might not like it but I would do it but
to bend over and spread your ass naked
is a whole different type of feeling
that's my hip-hop station is harmless
every night instead of Moria and janae
ioki and uh Chris Brown post the beat
yeah it's the song when she thought
about eating behind my groceries ah not
my cup of tea I don't think I'll be
eating anybody's behind like groceries I
like my groceries from Publix not from
panty drawers somehow songs magically
just make people want to throw money
I think the strippers they'll have a big
part of whether a song works at night if
you're a gentleman and you're in the
club and this girl's actually twerking
her life away sweating is shaking in
some of the convincing you that this
song is it the DJs and the dancers are
more like ANR's and we hear hits and we
love to dance too and we know what we
like dance too and we know a hit and we
hear it
music is generated usually first through
the script club's its underground and
that's where it comes first it grows
it's like roots of a tree and it grows
from the strip club and then it goes to
the dance club and when it graduates
from the commercial clubs it usually
goes to the radio huge' might be mr.
magic City he really started like he's
the one artist that I know that every
song every other song in strip club is a
future song when you look from the
outside looking in your thing I'm just
future DJ but when you know us they know
the story and know Atlanta then you'll
know how me and future became DJ ESCO in
the future I grew up house full of
people at ease on dope well good of
might be on drugs how much he's might
use it somewhere might serve it but that
man said you know me my uncle's know I
used to look up to the budget like the
hustle mentality
I love the fancy cars I used to have I
love the way these to dress I love they
changed the money I just see them count
I love how people react when they pull
up it gave me a chance to be able to see
certain things that I liked and I was
like I just had to find my way what I
was good at in life so I can get those
things I just had faked it taught me I
thought I had the most talent until I
met him you see I'm saying it's like you
think you're the most talented person
and then you meet someone my telling to
you that's how I was their future but I
knew if everyone knew we were best
friends and then they would think I was
just playing his music because we were
best friends
so we heared the fact that we are
friends they not even putting it to the
to together like that's a dude was
thanking with you they would call future
and say future called DJ ESCO
and tell him thanks man I was in magic
cities playing your music every time I
go in magic cities playing your music
future and we be side by side in this
house right here in this house on
speakerphone laughing yeah we're doing
it's working so we kept it a secret and
he's a superstar and by the time they
found out
we did it was it was too late he's gone
he's future Thank You Magic City if your
record isn't playing in Magic City then
it's not hot you cheat
Jeezy food and now cool America you
don't gotta make something happen
turning on the song anyway you can you
gotta get out there and get it like
sunset if it's what makes them shake if
it's what makes them spend money then
that's what they play they're not gonna
play a record that's not gonna have
nobody buying drinks and nobody shaking
ass and nobody spending money
fortunately for us whenever makes them
shake comes on everybody eats the Alpha
to make it seem as new tonight we got to
turn up for the grand finale
oh cool America as soon as you go in
there is a different world
even my world a chance they start
walking different everybody's rich
whether they return that is just the
persona if I have money I'm around money
so I feel like I have money just the
fact that I'm around money a lot of
people come to Magic City to show off
you're gonna get two Bentley's in the
Ferraris pulling up you're gonna get to
change you're gonna get the diamonds I
mean if you even come to magic and show
out imagine that means you're somebody
magic city is just a good wholesome
place a lot of networking goes on it's a
who's who because you never know who may
come from a basketball player or
politician might take his jacket off
coming with his blue jeans no I don't
even know he's in here all people
money's green and that's all this is
about
[Applause]
[Music]
sendou play my way a bit I ordered up a
bag of [ __ ] only
you want people to look at you and then
they can look at the girls but they
don't wanna look at me throw some money
to the top of the girls his power money
power I could throw this money on her
ass I don't give up about his money it's
just the fact I can throw her money on a
person and she likes it you know that I
I'm just threw money on your ass and you
love it
it's a rush got it throws money like ya
do it
no se is not for this oh whoa she might
get paper cut
so wrong with these people in another
thousand
[Music]
strippers are looking for the ballplayer
in the corner the rapper in the section
the actor over there where's the money
yet who's spending the might what does
the dope boys you can't forget the dope
boys the drug dealers they got the money
and they're throwing more money than the
ball plans because this Shawn the ball
players we make money too it's Street
stuff going on with the corporate it's a
mix of money going on when the strippers
that's what they're looking for ok who
who got the money because really I don't
want to strip for the rest of my life I
gotta get out of here too
how am I gonna get out of here and still
be able to live my lifestyle
I've seen so much money that it feels
like you're walking on plush carpet
strippers are walking out with trash
bags like Santa Claus Christmas basket
trash bags full of money either you can
crawl on the floor to get your money or
you can have someone else pick it up
it's a hierarchy type of deal you know
like it's a hundred dollars on the floor
I don't not picking this up here it's $5
kidding $10 can you pick my money up for
me if it's 5,000 you're like I don't
mind getting my hands dirty I'll pick it
up myself isn't that the American dream
you neither are the one that pursued
your dreams or you wake up and you work
for the person that do so if you want to
live that life you have to get up and
make some shape we're getting older
you're not getting younger
you've got to stack your money yet
because man wouldn't it hurt to go from
making the thousand dollars a night to
making $10 even $20 an hour I'm like I
rather get my money off the floor every
day I sees dancers that are addicted to
the pole to the pole money quit just
like telling a gambler don't gamble the
gamblers are gonna gamble dancers are
gonna dance sometimes they feel like in
their head their best option being
average has never been an option for me
I think that I could go from instead of
making you know $1,000 a night with my
clothes off I could make ten thousand
plus with my clothes on just to show up
somewhere my goal is to definitely
become a bigger entertainer with my
clothes off I've seen some girls get out
of the game what I call it success yes
because they got out is it what they had
in mind know what you have in mind is
here and you're usually end up finding
something in this realm
frame a frame chrome was just been a
rich it there's been a billion nut and I
want Fame people dock and he really
loves your club he really love that no I
just did that because that was a
business for me I used it as a business
I took advantage of opportunity if he
ain't got the most money what you gonna
use so you got to use the attempt you
gotta use the charisma you got to use
the way you talk you got to use your
look but you got to use just your way
you dress you know I'm saying you might
have to use a friend
everybody have a story a story where
they started but that ain't what you
want to finish sometimes the story might
start off a little screwed up but at the
end you want to make sure your story
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all about status right now and it's
it's sad but we're victims of our own
culture right now because looking the
role is as important as being wrong the
music doesn't help the music doesn't
help you know we kind of act like we
don't need the real substance in life
the music just talks about girls it just
talks about drugs and it talks about
cars and they talks about all the
superficial stuff so it doesn't help
that people have a hard time separating
reality from entertainment you know
because it is there is a line there's a
thick line it's not Finland it's a
pretty thick line between reality and
entertainment I guess I've been around
long enough to realize that a lot of it
is just a front
I've been around money I've seen money
I've seen the absence of money and what
it does I realized that and wasting it
just to impress people isn't really the
way to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know tricks like Chris old trick but I
can make it was just picking your
puto Toki hit me well when you walk in I
used to be flapping there I'm honking I
was the urban I'm sad fire why I still
have my [ __ ] on a horse I'd double
bed like Cossack or lighter net new push
[ __ ] tonight working light leave man
two bad [ __ ] in I got a man the way I
made the word once feel kind of a
tipping on the person you're crazy man
why la manche y la manche manche
[Music]
[Music]